[Music]
i'm tina hesman say i'm a senior writer
at science news magazine
and i cover molecular biology
and i'm erin garcia de jesus a general
assignment reporter at science news but
since january of 2020 teen and i have
mostly been covering the coronavirus and
covid19
we're here because science news is
turning 100
and as part of our centennial
celebration we're talking to scientists
about some big ideas in their fields
we have with us now
four experts or scientists whose
research
is
helping us learn to combat the
coronavirus and i'll let them introduce
themselves
hi i'm mark dennison i'm a professor of
pediatrics at vanderbilt university
medical center in nashville tennessee
and i have been studying coronaviruses i
guess since 1984.
mostly focusing on their replication
replication targets and more recently on
antivirus
hi my name is akiko iwasaki i'm a
professor of immunobiology at the yale
university school of medicine i'm also
an investigator of the howard hughes
medical institute
my lab studies antiviral immunity
prior to studying sars cov2 we were
studying different viruses including
herpes simplex virus influenza zika
rhinovirus and others
and since march of 2020 we
pivoted to studying source cov2
infection and immunity
hi my name is david martinez i'm a
postdoctoral scholar
in the barrick lab at the university of
north carolina
in addition to that i am a hannah gray
fellow of the howard hughes medical
institute
and prior to covet 19 then i had also
studied viral immunity to a number of
different viruses including hiv
in dengue virus as a flavivirus model
and at the start of the coving 19
epidemic then our lab
rapidly shifted our focus uh to this
novel coronavirus and we've been
studying
uh the immunity to source coronavirus ii
and even sars-related viruses and just
the greater better beta coronavirus
genus ever since
hi i'm kanta subarao i'm the director of
a whole collaborating center for
reference and research on influenza in
melbourne australia the number professor
in the department of microbiology and
immunology at the university of
melbourne
i was previously at the nih for many
years
i worked on influenza for most of my
career and
started working on sars actually with
the great introduction by mark denison
back in 2002 um when i was at the nih
and we had a very active sars program
for about five years working with the
barrack club and with mark
and about five years ago i moved to
australia um where i primarily work on
influenza but of course since um
since the emergence of stars coronavirus
ii we've been working on stars too as
well
fantastic thanks all of you for those
great introductions of yourselves we're
so excited to learn and hear what you
guys have to say today
um akiko our first question is actually
for you so you mentioned that before the
pandemic you were not working on
coronaviruses you pivoted in march 2020
and then um i was wondering if you could
tell us a little bit about what that was
like to pivot your research
yeah so this was quite abrupt um as you
can imagine
until like as i said march of 2020 we
were working on a variety of different
viruses
and also cancer immunology and everyone
was doing their own thing
and of course the school was shut down
for research other than
uh those that are dedicated to studying
cytoskeleb2 and
of course as a viral immunologist i was
very motivated to study this new
coronavirus and trying to understand the
immune responses that are happening in
the patients
and so we set up a biorepository called
impact yale where we would collect
longitudinal biospecimen from patients
in the hospital
and that's how we sort of started to
study immune responses as they happen in
the patients
and every day um
was an excitement because we learned you
know all kinds of things on a daily
basis and at the same time it was very
scary because we didn't have a vaccine
at the time i wanted to make sure my lab
members are safe
we took every precaution we we can and
thankfully none of us got infected but
it was also a scary time for everyone
well mark you
you obviously were studying
coronaviruses and you mentioned that
you've been working on
some antivirals
maybe you can talk a little bit about
how we have uh developed treatments
against the coronavirus and and where
you see that going next
well let's see this is what what do we
have like 12 hours is that what we have
here
well
our focus had really been on the viral
polymerase and on and on the novel um
proofreading
exonuclease that
is in code which was really first
described in a virus infection in my lab
back in 2007
and that had sort of led me to
interacting
with other scientists and particularly
polymerase biologists like old pearson
colorado state and craig cameron who was
at penn state at the time and sang up
because this enzyme seemed to be
knocking out viral
the capacity of nucleoside analogues to
inhibit coronal viruses
we wanted to try to find compounds that
would work just really biochemically or
in genetically you know to really
inhibit virus replication
so
we had been really working on
fundamental principles of replication
and starting then around 2013 we
established our collaboration with
gilead and
uh and with our long-term collaboration
with unc
and when we discovered that this
compound which we didn't know about what
it was at first was uh because we were
working with it blindly was from dust
severe and showed that this inhibited
the virus so dramatically
we then really pivoted
back starting in 2014 to thinking about
the capacity of these to actually
inhibit coronaviruses broadly we were
interested in time of course in mirrors
and using our model viruses as well
and sars and so sars kobe and then mers
and working at these and showing this
and i think our enthusiasm just really
sort of grew and grew as these
first uh reductive here and then the
drug pidd 1931 that became mullen to
peer here
both showed this really impressive
dramatic capacity to bypass this
proofreading function inhibit the virus
replication
we
uh i
i started learning what i call learning
drug development as a second language
late in life where i wasn't very smart
but i was really enthusiastic
and we and we were also seeing the
capacity of these viruses of other bad
viruses etc to infect human cells so
we started sort of uh
pounding the drum and standing up on the
street corner and preaching
that pandemics were coming
and that we needed to be prepared for
them and so we were really it just
positioned us to be able to do that and
publishing that work right before this
started i think was just
i think it's unusual to call it
serendipity in the face of a pandemic
but we're grateful that we were in a
position to do that so i think where
we're going is um
right now obviously the nih and the
whole world is really interested in this
issue of particular orally available
antivirals targeting multiple different
targets that can be broadly active
against coronaviruses at least the virus
the family of coronaviruses
if not more broadly against other
viruses as well so i think this renewed
emphasis and sort of this dramatic focus
around antivirals is important because i
think we're seeing that
as good as the vaccines are going to be
we're still going to have people who are
at risk people who are you know
compromised people who need
who need either prophylaxis or they need
treatment and that's something that
we're very excited to continue to try to
probe
right and so i mean there's been
obviously remdezavir is now approved for
treating a covid19
for people who are in the hospital
and uh won't appear in every
new peer reviewer
new purpose
which i learned recently
is named for thor's hammer well that's
maybe apocryphal but that's what i was
told by one of the people who developed
it the mole near
thor's hammer so that's where i heard it
came from
right so
anyway that has recently had some
encouraging results in um
in clinical trials
for people who have been newly diagnosed
um
why didn't we have these antivirals
before i mean we have we've had corona
viruses around well
i don't know that there was more than
one or two funded programs in the world
working on chronovirus antivirals before
the pandemic um
we may have been the only one in the
united states that i'm aware of that was
focused specifically on that
i think part of it is because antivirals
are fundamentally difficult they're more
difficult than vaccines so apologies to
vaccinologists
and the reason for that is because
viruses um
you can work on a vaccine to work
outside of a cell an antiviral has to
work inside of a cell since viruses are
obligated intracellular parasites and
they use host cell mechanism so anything
you do with an antiviral
fundamentally is going to be targeting
the inside of a cell and mechanisms that
may be common to the cell and the virus
so
and also viruses are exceptionally good
at evading these and finding something
that can damage the virus without
damaging the cell is
profoundly challenging and i think maybe
a final answer is because there had
never been sort of a manhattan project
type approach where everybody in the
world was looking at all their compounds
was really willing to target this and
that the resources were brought to bear
to bring immunologists animal model
geneticists by rologis
biochemists structural biologists
evolutionary biologists
together to to try to understand quickly
do we have targets that could work and
how do we develop those rapidly
right
well i i want to switch over and and
talk to kanta a little bit about well
you know this is a pandemic it's global
and
you're in australia on the other side of
the world from the rest of us who are in
the united states
um
can you tell us a little bit about what
the experience has been like in
australia and for the rest of the world
because you've been one of the people
who have been monitoring the spread
of the virus and you know what are you
seeing
especially in terms of
variants and uh
and what we can expect out of this
coronavirus
sure um i mean i think that the
experience of the pandemic has been very
different in different parts of the
world
australia is a huge
island
and they closed their borders very early
we closed our borders in february of
last year
completely so
there was no further there was very
little introduction
um of the virus into australia and and
the same was through in um
new zealand in taiwan and hong kong
singapore a lot of countries closed
their borders so their experience in the
pandemic is really quite different from
what the us the uk europe and so on so
what we also did in australia was they
instituted a mandatory two-week
quarantine for anybody returning to the
country or coming into the country so
that two-week period was actually long
enough to essentially capture any
infection that was brought in
so seeding of the community just wasn't
happening very much
it did happen when we had breakdowns in
the hotel quarantine system uh which did
happen
but we've had you know we were really
protected through the first year and
something of this pandemic however the
delta variant has really changed all of
that because it is far more infectious
and i don't know if it's partly pandemic
fatigue
australians have been incredibly
compliant i must say having spent most
of my adult life in america um it's you
know wearing a mask was just not a
political statement it was just done
because we were asked to do it
and people were very compliant with all
of the restrictions
so the country did very well um
unfortunately now of course we're
dealing with the fact that you know
delta is here and it's spreading um
we're dealing with the fact that
australia got a little complacent um and
instituted and um and um
actually deployed vaccine rather slowly
um so we were pretty late to the party
for vaccines um and only now are really
catching up so now we've overtaken the
united states in the number that are
fully vaccinated um and
again maybe it's complete the fact that
aussies are a little more compliant but
in many parts of the country more than
80 percent well over 80 percent of the
population has had their first dose and
will get their second dose within the
next few weeks so i think we will reach
um and canberra which is the country's
capital has over 99 percent of first
vaccination so they will be the most
vaccinated city in the world probably
soon
so you know it is it's been quite
different
and it's been a little heartbreaking for
me to watch
the pandemic transpire in the u.s i
worked for the us government for most of
my adult life and it's been really quite
devastating to watch
the size of the pandemic and the fact
that you know there was such a breakdown
in the in the support for public health
over the years that you know essentially
this pandemic was such a full-blown
event in the united states um
and even now when the numbers are coming
under control it's still far greater
than
you know
australia has ever seen um through the
whole pandemic so
in a sense you know sitting far away
it's been a it has been a bit of a mixed
bag of
you know how i feel about it i mean a
lot of people here say oh aren't you
just so glad you're here and i think no
everybody i know is in america
and i you know it's very hard to be far
away my family's there um so it's hard
to be far away and observe this from a
distance but on the other hand you know
in terms of science it's been amazing
um and you know
for
so much i spent a huge number of my
nighttime hours on zoom calls and phone
calls um and the
the
progress of science has been you know
just breathtaking
yeah kante you mentioned the delta
variant i'm curious what your thoughts
are
about
you know things were looking better
before the delta variant came there were
other variants as well that people were
concerned about like what are your
thoughts on
how things would have gone had
that like particularly the delta variant
not
coming um so that's a good question i
mean it's a hypothetical because of
course the delta variant is very much
here and has taken over
all over the world
and i don't think it's going to be the
last variant we see i think we will see
additional variants emerge as law and i
think the reason we're seeing variants
is because
of the burden of infection in the
population around the world
and um and we could talk about vaccine
equity and their doses and so on but
until we vaccinate more of the world
we're going to see
um infections in unvaccinated people and
the emergence of variants
so the delta without the delta variant
the vaccines were looking fantastic
um and they continued to do very well
in protection against severe disease so
if the initial goal and the initial goal
of vaccination was to prevent severe
illness and death and to protect our
health care systems and they've done
very well with that even with the delta
variant now i think if the beta variant
had actually taken off and spread around
the world we would have been in even
worse trouble because the beta variant
actually is let is less well inhibited
by the antibody elicited by the original
muhan strain
against the delta variant i think the
big issue is that it is highly
infectious and that even people that are
fully vaccinated can get infected now i
think it is not entirely clear yet how
much a fully vaccinated person who gets
infected with the delta variant what is
the risk of them actually spreading it
to other fully vaccinated people i think
that is a piece of data we don't have
yet
uh we do know that vaccine induced
immunity the antibody titers are
dropping
with time
we know that the delta variant is very
thick
and is spreading we also know that fully
vaccinated people can get reit can get
infected with the delta variant and they
can shed virus at least by pcr
at a similar node as an unvaccinated
person but the bit of data that i don't
see yet is how many people are fully vac
how many fully vaccinated people a fully
vaccinated person can affect
so i think our hope is to actually get
the level of vaccination up in the world
um so that we can drive down some of
this burden of infection
speaking of vaccines and variants this
brings me to david um you are
you and your colleagues are working on
you know like next generation vaccines
thinking about the future of a world
where we have lots of different variants
or even other emerging coronaviruses and
working on something that could tackle
all of those in a universal chronovirus
vaccine
um
what
uh what do you think have we learned
about the potential for these types of
shots and from your work
yeah so i think uh
so far based on all the data we've seen
um then
achieving at least a more broad vaccine
at least against the cousin of
the cousins of sars chronovirus 2
might be a more readily achievable thing
to do
so we've
been able to at least pre-clinically
develop
uh vaccine concepts against uh
stars-related viruses including sars
chronovirus ii and the critical variant
such as the beta variant that kanta
mentioned that is relatively more
neutralization resistant compared to
other variants
so in terms of the broad spectrum
vaccines against the
sars related viruses or the sarbaco
viruses then i think that's that might
be a
uh easier target to achieve so we have
uh a couple of different vaccine
concepts that we've been involved with
and so far uh
both of those concepts appear to be
uh
appear to be highly protective against a
number of different of those viral
infections
i think moving forward what will be a
more difficult target to
hit will be a more broad or a beta
coronavirus vaccine for example that not
only covers the starch-related viruses
but also includes for example group 2c
coronaviruses which include mers or even
the common cold coronaviruses
so you mean we
might not have to have holes anymore
uh that that would be ideal and that of
course remains an aspirational goal but
i think moving forward that is certainly
where
we would all like to get in terms of
developing a beta coronavirus widely
protected vaccine
that could not only
prevent the infection from cyrus
chronovirus ii but also more distant
uh
coronaviruses
but of course that that that is
currently uh being tested preclinically
so we don't yet know if that'll be
possible in in humans
can you talk a little bit about what
makes these universal vaccines different
from the ones that we have now against
the coronavirus i mean most of them are
directed against the spike protein or
they are
are killed
whole viruses
um
is is that kind of approach you're
taking like you get a
a spike protein that that is one size
fits all or are you doing a different
type of approach
so a number of different approaches are
being tried uh we've been involved in at
least two of them and one of the
approaches that we've been primarily
involved in
um is actually expanding the breadth of
the spike by ad mixing uh the different
immunogenic domains so the ntd the rbd
and the s2 and generating chimeric
spikes and then with the
advent of the mrna technology then
you're able to multiplex the delivery of
these vaccines so that is one approach
that has
shown immense early success at least in
my so far
and
in another approach that we've also been
involved in
is the delivery of a nanoparticle
vaccine that expresses the rbd
of sars-related viruses and the rbd of
uh stars chronovirus ii for example
actually shares a
highly conserved signature
with a number of different
source-related viruses so we've actually
identified monoclonal antibodies that
are broadly protective against a number
of different stars related viruses and
if you deliver the
part of the rbd that has this broadly
protective epitope then you can readily
induce broadly protective immunity in
mice so what's important and what's in
what's promising is that you have
at least uh
you have more than one platforms that
can achieve this and i think uh that
raises optimism for me
yeah well um akiko uh you know we've
been talking about vaccine immunity but
you've been studying a lot about what
goes wrong
in the body or what just happens in the
body when you get infected with the
coronavirus can you talk a little bit
about what you've been learning and how
is how is this virus
response different
than other coronaviruses or just other
respiratory viruses
yeah so one of the first learnings that
we got from studying these patients
was
that there is this in the severe cases
the patients are generally unable to
control the virus well especially quick
enough and what happens is that once the
patients fail to do so the virus spreads
through into the lung and damage some of
the very delicate tissues that are
required for
oxygen
you know gas exchange and so on and
that's sort of leading to this pneumonia
phenotype
and when we study those patients what
we're finding is that there is misfiring
of the immune response
that normally we think of antiviral
immunity mediated by one branch of the
immune response which is called the type
1 immunity but what we're seeing is that
those patients are also engaging type 2
and type 3 immunity which are normally
reserved for fighting parasite infection
or fungal infection or bacterial
infection
and so what appears to us is sort of
like a misfiring of the immune response
that trying to contain this virus you
know with any tools that we have on hand
but actually that's resulting in a
pathological outcome in some of these
patients because it's not a
well-intended you know antiviral
mechanism
so that was the first insight we
obtained from studying the patients in
real time
and later on we also studied uh sex
differences in immune responses that
occur in these patients and
you know as we all know male sex is a
risk factor for severe and lethal covet
and what what we learned is that um in
the early phase of the immune response
women tended to generate more robust
t-cell immunity
whereas men
failed to do so but they
instead engaged inflammatory responses
and that may have led to sort of the
lack of control of the virus that leads
to this misfiring later on that i just
mentioned
so we we also learned that there is a
difference in the way male and female
immune responses are dealing with the
virus and that may explain to some
extent some of the you know different
risk factors that we're seeing based on
sex
i mean there's also
a lot of people have been talking more
about long-term effects of viral
infections and long-term symptoms that
you might have after after you've
you know recovered from the
the virus infecting your body it's
supposedly gone but you still have a lot
of symptoms
long coved and i know you've been really
involved in that particular field as
well so can you talk a little bit about
what you've learned in that arena
yeah absolutely so that that's what i'm
most concerned about right now is the
you know the lack of diagnosis um and
care and therapy
that can help people with long covet
and so long covet can happen um in a
large fraction of uh hospitalized
patients who are discharged alive
anywhere estimate between 50 to 70
percent of these people are still having
lingering symptoms after months of
discharge
and long coffee can also happen in
people who had milder infection were
never hospitalized but those patients
may also develop long covet you know
the estimated percentages are varies but
between 5 to 30 percent
so even if we take a conservative
estimate of five percent uh that's a
large number of people given how many
millions of people are infected with
this virus and the latter type um is
also um there are more women in in
middle age that's enriched in that
population
and so we currently have a couple of
hypotheses we're trying to um dissect
one is that the long covet can happen as
a result of a potentially a viral
reservoir or
some fragments of virus rna or protein
that deposits in some tissue that's
causing chronic inflammation
the other hypothesis we're pursuing is
that
this acute infection causes triggers
autoimmune disease
uh which can have long-term consequences
which involve multiple organ systems and
so long covet um has at least 200
different symptoms that have been
reported involving like pretty much
every organ system you can imagine
and so we really need to find out what's
going on in these patients so we can
treat them better
are there good treatments at this point
now i wish there were some good
treatments um i'm not sure if the
antivirals would actually work in these
patients if it is actually a persistent
virus infection that might have some
um you know beneficial effect but we
have to remember the long covet is
likely going to be heterogeneous disease
that it's not one thing that's causing
all these symptoms so
if we can identify let's say cluster of
patients that
may be you know driven by persistent
virus versus those that are driven by
autoimmunity or a combination thereof
we can start to think about rational
therapy for these people
but first is really to identify what's
going on so we can have a better therapy
and the one thing that seems to be
helping patients is the vaccination
actually
so there are now reports demonstrating
that you know between 40 to 60 of the
long haulers that receive the vaccine
feel improvement in their symptoms
whereas about 20 percent are getting
more symptoms so
that gives us a little bit of idea
as to what kind of triggers might
improve their symptoms and
you know what we can do to help them
so i have a question do you think that
that means that
this implicates
um
a persistent virus infection uh or is it
a is it a down regulated does the is it
causing a down regulation of a
particular immune response that's
detrimental
yeah so mark that's um both
possibilities are currently holding up
um it's you know
one possibility is just the simply that
the vaccine is inducing really good
immune response that clears any viral
reservoir in which case you can have
like a permanent cure
some people are getting a permanent cure
from vaccine well vast majority of
people are not getting that they're
getting a temporal improvement in their
symptoms and it's not that all of their
symptoms go away so
that to me tells me that potentially
it's maybe cytokines or other factors
that's induced by the vaccination
that's sort of acting on autoreactive
cells to shut down their cytokine
production or potentially antibody
production but it's not a permanent
solution
so we really need to understand like
what's going on in these patients so we
can provide a permanent solution
tina could i comment on that in terms of
related to antivirals
briefly i
you know and i think the nice thing for
one of these kind of forums is to take
us a little bit beyond and not be afraid
to sort of thought think and speculate a
little bit because i think
we're also
we're also deluged with data and
information every day
well one thing for sure is that
antivirals work best when there's a
viral target they don't work at all if
they're direct acting antivirals that
are targeting the virus they don't work
at all if there's no virus present or if
the disease is not viral related
and i think when you know
dust severe was used
uh latent infection because at the time
of course at the height of the epidemic
pre-vaccines
the the issue was can we save people's
lives can we get them off ventilators
and so and that fact that it was iv also
encouraged that and so i was actually
surprised that it had any impact at all
because all the studies that have been
done in ralph's lab and my my lab and
others had shown that you use the drug
early and it worked you use it late and
it doesn't work and that was true with
both multipure beer and vegetable
you know and i've been thinking about
this in terms of persistent virus
infection because the very first models
that i at the lab i went in in stanley
perrman's lab in 1984 he was working on
a model of viral persistence and mouse
hepatitis virus whereas maternal if the
dams were immunized and the infants were
infected
they would not develop a severe acute
disease but they would develop
persistent disease that led to chronic
myelinating encephalitis right so led to
demyelination of the brain
and that was the model that i was
working on mouse hepatitis virus for all
those years which was really an
immunological model of some ways of but
it also was associated with long-term
persistent infection
and so i i think this is particularly
interesting because you you
theoretically might have a place for a
an effective antiviral that decreased or
you know allowed you to significantly
decrease viral load over a long period
of time that could be taken orally so
that's i hadn't thought of that actually
until this moment i've been thinking
prophylactically or very early in
therapy but there might be a role of
that associated with fact with
immunization because they're not
mutually exclusive
so that's an interesting idea
yeah i love that thought i mean what we
need is a good clinical trial yes
yes
and i would even say um mark adding to
that you know potentially another
concept that could be explored in
conjunction with antivirals uh could be
fc region optimized monoclonal
antibodies uh optimized for killing of
virally infected cells okay you have to
unpack that
what
what does that mean those words
fcy
so so so antibodies so i'm an antibody
person um
so monoclonal antibodies have two
different major regions they have the
antigen binding region so the fab region
or the fc region which is the part in
the antibody that actually talks to the
immune system
so a number of different recent papers
from different groups have demonstrated
that the fc region is actually required
for
not only protection but you can actually
improve the function of these antibodies
if you
make them if you if you modify them in a
way that they can talk to the immune
system a little bit better
so
that could potentially be um
an additive therapy that you could
explore not just in this the context of
uh long covet for example but if you
were to maybe combine that with an
antiviral so now you have an antiviral
that's targeting the virus and you have
a different type of biologic that's
still antiviral but it's actually
engaging the immune system
and so that would be different from the
monoclonal antibodies that we've heard
about like the ones that are being used
for early treatments
correct so so
with even without modifying even without
optimizing the f's the part in the
antibody that talks to the immune system
the antibodies will
will do their thing anyways so this this
would like you correctly uh surmised
this would actually include for example
the astrazeneca cocktail or the
regeneron cocktail or the bristol meyer
squid cocktail so this could potentially
be
at least you know in the small
proportion of patients that akiko
mentions that
uh could have symptoms long covered
symptoms that are driven by the virus
then this could potentially be a an
additional therapy that could be
explored
well i i do want to get all of your
thoughts on um
what made this
coronavirus into a pandemic virus i mean
i've been writing a long time about
infectious diseases and there's been
many different candidates you know
mostly different influenza viruses you
know avian influenzas particularly
and none of them have have really become
the pandemic that was promised
and then this one just sort of
came out of the blue and
suddenly it was everywhere
so
what if we learned about this virus what
makes it so special that that it could
be a pandemic virus
i think the scary thing is that nothing
makes it so special from other
coronaviruses
no i
i
i think
well i'll wait till mark finishes
jumping
i'll let you go go ahead
to me continue
two big differences um are
from from all the
avian influenza viruses that have failed
to start a pandemic or sars or mars
there are two things one is that this
virus spreads efficiently from person to
person
by the airborne route
which did not happen with mers or sars
the second really big difference is that
in both tsars and mers
everybody who was infected had symptoms
and with this virus infection we have a
lot of asymptomatic individuals people
who don't even know they're infected who
are spreading the virus so to me those
were the two game changers i was
um i first heard about the
person-to-person transmission at the
very end of january of 2020
and i was at a flu meeting and i said oh
my goodness this sounds like food this
does not sound like sars at all and to
me that is really what made the
difference in making this virus able to
cause a pandemic
i think kant and i were having these
conversations in 2003
is if sars escaped so we were watching
it if it escapes into
the indian subcontinent or the african
continent or in places where there were
public health we were concerned there
might be public health you know control
issues in some places in the world
uh war zones etc
that it would take off
and uh and certainly you saw super
spreading events and you saw we all
thought that that was going to be the
one
what it had but it had to kill his heel
not achilles heels it required
symptomatic
severe respiratory infection for
transmission
and and i think that that one achilles
heel the other thing is it's it's it's
efficient so there was this issue of
efficiency of transmission without
symptoms and second is
that it's are not really never rose very
high except for these super spreading
events so those two things really made
it controllable by public health
measures that haven't been successful
with with covet when i said nothing
special about it what i was i shouldn't
be cavalier about it what i meant was
that we don't understand in
coronaviruses what would make one
different from another right there's no
obvious signal except for the potential
capacity of this particular spike
protein to show this kind of dramatic
variation
but when you look at it it looks like an
another family member you put them side
by side and they're going to look really
really similar
the number of nucleotide differences
across the replicase gene is
exceptionally small or they're highly
related
and so what makes it
unique we don't know and that that's
what i meant from the virological
perspective but i think from the
perspective of
the differences we've been worrying and
all of our crying from the mountaintops
was about mers was
this is transmitted from camels there's
limited transmission from human to human
but if it gains the capacity for direct
respiratory spread it was maintaining a
30 to 40 mortality rate over about an
eight year period of people who got it
and we were concerned that this was one
that would escape and then myrrh seems
to have had the bad habits of both
sorrows
and mers kobe but we do not know why
and i think that's what is the important
point
and i think fire logically that's true
for influenza viruses as well
we
do not yet understand what makes one
influenza virus highly transmissible
from person to person and another not
and that's been an area of interest and
study um because seasonal influenza
viruses transmit very well avian
influenza viruses generally do not
fortunately um and there are avian
influenza viruses like h5n1 and h7n9
that have been very very high case
fatality rates but
fortunately do not spread efficiently
from person to person so there's been a
lot of interest in the flu community as
well to try to understand what those
determinants of transmission are
so that we can then do
a better job at risk assessment when
viruses emerge in or cause zoonotic
infections to know that this one is one
to watch and contain immediately versus
another that you know we could actually
um have small outbreaks and still not be
yet
at risk of pandemic
so one thing that i've written a lot
about this year is the fact that uh this
does seem to be
transmitted through the air
um
whereas we
didn't used to think that that was sort
of the the major route that respiratory
viruses were transmitted which
to me i guess now doesn't really make
sense that they wouldn't be transmitted
through the air um
but is there
is there anything
that
else that we've learned that you think
is surprising about that so this is an
area that is fascinating and it's an
area where
it's been very clear that virologists
and physicians um speak a very different
language from aerosol biologists
they both know a lot but they spoke a
completely different language use
different terminology different measures
um and so the medical community
basically said that anything that it was
all based on particle size and that if a
particle was more than five microns in
size that you emit from the respiratory
tract it will settle out of the air
within three meters
um between three maybe within three feet
or one meter and that's why hospital
beds were always more than a meter apart
and that any virus particle that stay
that was under five microns could remain
suspended in the air could travel
greater distances and was then aerosol
transmissible
aerosol scientists tell us that is
complete nonsense that um the particle
size is more like a hundred microns not
five
and that particles actually that are the
size of the particles changes
essentially as soon as you breathe them
out as they dry out the particle size
changes so there's been a um and i think
this last year there was a fantastic
national academy of engineering um
workshop that brought aerosol scientists
and engineers together with virologists
and physicians and infection control
people so they're starting to break down
those barriers and understand each other
so i think the the science of how
viruses or all pathogens are spread
through the air is is a absolutely
uh fascinating field where lots has to
happen because we i mean i'm hearing
about um
built environments and you know how do
you ventilate um because normally we
ventilate in indoor environments for
comfort not for health
um
and so there's a lot that has to happen
in that space and i think the public
health community was the slowest to the
party there was an unwillingness to use
the word airborne transmission
even though the data was staring us in
our faces
and so
i think it had to do with a number of
complex issues such as if you label
something airborne transmissible then it
changes the type of personal protective
equipment that you need to then provide
to people and there was deemed to be a
shortage of it so how could you
recommend that if you couldn't supply it
but i think it is time to sort of step
back from all of that and look at the
data
talk to our colleagues in other fields
and really break down some of these
barriers and understand
what is happening and how we can
mitigate some of this
yeah well
you mentioned talking to colleagues in
other fields
it seems to me that
science has gotten incredibly
collaborative across fields and across
the world you know
huge numbers of scientists coming
together to work on these problems um
you know what what's your guys's
perspective is it
have you seen that or
are you seeing siloing what's what's
going on in terms of
how this pandemic may be changing
research
yeah i think that's one of the biggest
change that i've experienced personally
is that you know prior to the pandemic
we were pretty much doing things in
silos
a scientist but with the pandemic
you know we've reached out to everyone
who has the expertise and who's asking
the questions that you're interested in
not just throughout the school or
throughout the states but throughout the
world so now we have multiple
collaborations all across the globe
really looking at anything from
you know immune pathogenesis to
vaccine effectiveness to
you know um
third dose you know what is mix and
match many many questions we can only
address
globally together and that's been a very
welcoming change for me like this team
science is really the future
and um i think the scientific community
like academic community has to catch up
with this
in terms of evaluating scientists you
know the old traditional metrics about
who's the last author who's the first
author you know this kind of
measurement is not conducive to kind of
promoting this team science effort
and so that's something that i think the
the community the scientific academic
sort of um environment has to change to
accommodate
do you think it will last beyond the
pandemic
i hope so i mean once you do the team
science you can't go backwards
i think i think if um a lot of um
i agree with the kika this has been
fantastic and and some countries have
done it kind of operationally at a
national level like the uk has done some
phenomenal
clinical trials and clinical evaluation
by
forming consortia um
and so it's not just organically i mean
it's happened because the government's
thrown money at the problem so so i
think the money that's been thrown at
the problem has helped a lot and i think
that oh my only worry about the
longevity of this kind of um
cohesiveness is if money dries up and we
can end up being in a competitive
environment again so i think that you
know funding agencies if they can
actually if they take away um
the the funding as the reason to compete
then they'll be able to
have much more collaboration
i have seen the rise and fall and rise
and fall from
uh sores and murrays
i think this is different because it's a
pandemic i think it's incorporating
something my question is are the
are the akikos going to stay in the
field
are they going to stay interested in
virology as the pressures on it become
more competitive that wasn't targeted
for you of course
but it's because it's so important to
have you in the field and that
we were a field that had one or two
immunologists and two or three
replication
people and you know three or four
structural biologists may be
if we were lucky um
and the question is i think it's it's
about infrastructure it's like bridges
it's like do you build them and then do
you maintain them
because i i think the answer is correct
i have more i've had more opportunities
in the last year to talk to
endonuclease and exonuclease biochemists
people who are developing small
molecules fragment-based screening
novel biochemical strategies that i ever
have i've had people reach out and want
my all of my mhv reporter viruses
because they now want to look at the
cell biology of coronaviruses and a bsl2
model and they want to try to understand
issues of entry and so that you know
things that i thought i was going to be
putting in the autoclave at the end of
my career i'm passing out around the
world and i'm thrilled
but i'll tell you the most important
thing i think is not
for people like me to establish team
science it's to have the david martinez
and the other people who come into the
field and who find the capacity to stay
so what are the issues associated with
that well there's a couple major ones
that i see one is stability of funding
and that they can count on that
two is that they that they find that um
that they can they can carry that work
forward in a way that's meaningful
if they want doing the hard work so you
know people ask me how did you stick
with coronavirus for 36 years and my
wife might have said well he's an idiot
that might have been the answer but um
but i think
the idea is that the ideas compel you so
much and you're willing to fight for
those ideas and go to the fundamental
science because if
everybody in the world is looking at the
rbd on the spike protein that isn't
going to last right that's not going to
last because people have to look at more
fundamental questions that kind of david
is approaching
and the final one is i think we need
yeah we need young we just need young
investigators and we need to support
them through the process and allow them
the time to develop and stay in these
fields and make them understand that
it's an area they can thrive in that's
what matt honestly to me that's the
issue of continuity that matters the
most
makes me almost feel a little bit guilty
because i was a virologist and then i
left to become a science journalist yeah
well you may have left very positive
reasons but a lot of people leave
because they don't feel it's a
sustainable career over the long haul
and that's a problem
yeah aaron uh
aaron became a science journalist
doing your internship with us
just at the point where the pandemic was
hitting so
this sort of the
the perfect person to have at the
at a very bad time but
perfect for us
um
which
you know she was really instrumental in
helping us properly communicate the
virology about this
we have done a terrible job
we've done a terrible job as scientists
of communicating
uh the terminology and doing it in a way
that is
is recognizable as understandable to
people and that engages them and lets
them understand it's complex and so it's
not a contradiction to say one day we're
developing a vaccine to try to prevent
infection and then we say well it didn't
prevent infection but boy is it you're
accomplishing the goal of preventing
severe disease and hospitalization and
death and that science evolves and that
is not static
if i could just add a point that um
perhaps hasn't been mentioned so to echo
mark i would say
of course uh understanding the
fundamental biology of not just
coronaviruses but other uh
other other viruses i think it's
absolutely critical but if i could just
add you know maybe an overarching theme
that we need to rethink and maybe
reinvent uh
in in redesign is how do we
change our pandemic preparedness
landscape so instead of sitting instead
of being a sitting duck just waiting for
a virus to emerge into a completely
naive human population is i think we
need to
start prioritizing
and investing more in pandemic
preparedness
on a more global level
not just pandemic preparedness in terms
of vaccine and monoclonal antibody or
therapeutic design but broad spectrum
antivirals uh and even just uh public
health infrastructure to be able to
rapidly respond to uh
a viral pandemic
or a pathogen pandemic
i mean to get a little bit back to the
idea that i mean science communication
is hard um
all of you have talked in some capacity
to
you know journalists like us throughout
the pandemic what are some of the
biggest challenges that you guys have
faced in either communicating
you know your research or just talking
about the science in general
well so i use multiple different
platforms to communicate um you know
twitter is the fastest the moment i type
people can see what i'm talking about um
i've also sort of engaged with more
traditional media newspapers television
radio shows and so on and i actually
decided in early pandemic to dedicate a
big portion of my life to doing science
communication
because i think it's important for
scientists to
speak you know from experts opinion you
know what what's going on explaining to
the lay public what is an immune system
you know what does anybody mean um how
does memory work all these basic
fundamental insights that
many people didn't have prior to
pandemic now people are are talking
about neutralizing antibody titers and
rvds and you know they have the lingo
to be able to understand and talk about
um immune system as well as viruses but
i i think that's
that was important to me that that we as
scientists communicate with the public
and i think all of us tried to do that
you know uh more than ever like i i've
never been in contact with so many
reporters prior to pandemic uh
occasionally i would talk to them about
this and that but this has just
completely changed the landscape
um and i i just hope that more people
will engage in this because uh we i
think the society needs scientists voice
needs our expertise and you know needs
people um to explain to them
uh you know about what's the future upon
them how do we contain it
all these issues so i think science
communication is is a big part of being
a scientist
and i do think that has going to that
comes back to what david was talking
about about preparing for the next
pandemic right because at the beginning
of all this
it was kind of the communication was not
amazing and so you know when the next
pandemic happens because it will
hopefully we'll be more prepared
so i think i think communication is
absolutely critical and people uh
scientists are not often not taught how
to communicate um so you know i was at
cdc at nih and had a little um you know
communications
workshops to attend
partly just so you don't embarrass the
government um but the university of
melbourne has one too um but i think to
me probably
um what we could have i think i think
the public is actually has been educated
very much though in the last year and a
half mrna rolls off people's tongues
they all know about boosting and you
know so it is amazing how much the
general public knows of science now um
but i think what we
probably
should have communicated better and this
is you know journalists as well as
scientists is that we were dealing with
something completely new
and that the information was going to
change
um and that it is our job
to be open to new information and to
change our thinking as information
evolves that simply changing what we're
saying doesn't mean that we are
untrustworthy that we have to find a way
to communicate that
trust should still be maintained and
that we're responding to new information
so unfortunately very often um
we are asked to give a definitive answer
and and it's almost phrase termed as if
you know if you've changed what you're
saying that
the previous version was false and it's
rather that we're fine-tuning it as we
go you know i've i've
i give answers sometimes that are
provocative and that the people don't
like they say how long is this going to
last i'm going i don't think you want to
ask me that
or
or they'll say what are you working on
now i say sarge kobe 3
because we're trying to prepare for the
next virus you know it's it's
and it's not really being glib what the
point i'm trying to make you know and i
tell people how long this is going to
last i said well the virus will let us
know
um
because
and you can't because it came back to
some of what kanto was saying earlier we
were talking about earlier about the
virus evolution we don't know
we just don't know and i and i think one
thing that i
knew what i've learned and new is to be
is that we need to have about you know
one part of science and about nine parts
of humility around this
and that if we're in a position to tell
people
this i start my things off i'm gonna
give you a talk today first i'm gonna
tell you
what
i know
what we've worked on and what our
results show and i'm going to put those
in context and then i'm going to tell
you what i think
and then i'm going to tell you what i
have no idea but i what is my
speculation about this i want you to put
those in context because the first is
data the second is my opinion and the
third is
my worry about it you know and and so
then i think that i've gotten responses
back from that a bit i really
appreciated that because it allowed me
to put things in context of what was
really information and what was opinion
uh what was informed opinion what was
speculation based on what you know
and i and i think that that is it also
says that in the face of a virus that is
evolving independent of us couldn't care
less about us that it's
it's going to do what it does and i've
been shocked and amazed by its its its
profound rapid evolutionary capacity
uh and that we don't know how long it
took oc43 and hku1 the human cold
coronaviruses we don't know how long it
took for them to become the way they
became it's not going to happen
overnight and people want to say well in
a year or so this is going to be a
common cold virus
it's not it's nonsense it might be
but the the the statement is nonsense
um and so i think that just this kind of
humility we haven't had and our
willingness to say i don't know i don't
know i don't know
no one's gonna keep interviewing us
because they'll stop because we don't
know
but it's the truth
and and i would i would say you know
adding to mark's point about uh
you know just saying what we don't know
and having humility i would think i i i
would add that a strategy that has
certainly worked for me
in terms of uh
communicating
with the public is
really um trying to communicate the
nuance in science and uh really not
speaking in absolute terms so uh just
you know coming with that humility of
saying you know in in real just like in
real life
nothing is or most things most of the
time are never a hundred or zero percent
there's always a spectrum there are
nuances and this is one of those things
that is so new for everyone that we just
don't know and we're learning as we go
yeah that is a good point um thank you
all for
those thoughts um we are coming up on
the end of our time so i just had one
final question because we wanted to end
on a hopeful note um after talking about
such a grim
uh
you know topic for an hour um
maybe very briefly each of you could
just talk
really quick about what has given you
hope over the past two years like one
thing that you know is your bright light
at the end of the tunnel
well what's given me hope is um sort of
the future
as mark said i think
supporting and encouraging the new
generation of scientists
is what's giving me hope and i i see it
in
my own eyes my trainees as well as
people around me or young scientists who
are now really engaging in
the science of long coverage science of
you know covet immunity
it really does give me hope and they're
so dedicated and talented and you know
driven
and that to me is the future and that's
how we fight the next pandemic is is by
developing and growing and nurturing the
next generation of scientists so that's
that's where i see the light
the single most thing that has given me
hope
is just watch
the community just come together
the scientific community come together
with industry
partners
to
which we saw the development of not just
not one but three safe and effective
vaccines in the u.s alone in less than
one year so
um
to me that's that's been one of the
silver linings of this whole thing is
seeing uh
you know if we let science take the
front seat then this is what we can
achieve together yeah i would add that
from my standpoint it's the
the new technologies and the new team
science and the sort of breaking down of
barriers
domestically and internationally
and
so many people from many different
fields have entered this field and
really contributed enormously
and that gives me great hope that um
that we will see the end of this and
that it will serve us well um with
future health threats
well
it gives me hope this particular viruses
is this this stunning
speed of development of vaccines and
antivirals people keep saying why is it
taking so long well it didn't uh even
seven years to develop you know
antivirals i mean and the fact that we
now understand the targets i think our
capacity to target this is good and it's
it's going to
serve as well both from vaccines
antivirals understanding of the immune
response all of this is is coming
together it's overwhelming for those of
us who try to keep up in any area but
and that's why we need good science
communication to help me find things to
read that i i haven't had time to read
the primary literature on
but i think this
just the fact of the people you have on
this
ranging across disciplines across
career stages
all focused on on a common
common enemy but a common area of
science and understanding that could
potentially lead us into the future new
models i think that's
the most hope the most hopeful thing
i think we could all use some help
keeping up with things that are
happening in the covid world it's all
moving so fast
um but again thank you all for taking
the time to talk with us this has been a
fascinating conversation i hope you all
have learned as much as we have and what
how much our viewers will um
viewers if you want to learn more about
covid19 and the coronavirus you can
always
visit our website at sciencenews.org
and connect with us on social media
thanks for joining us
happy anniversary
[Music]